I can feel it getting springier wow I'm
so out of shape so today I'm going to be
challenging myself to make tomato sauce
meatballs and pasta two ways so the
first way is using as many kitchen
appliances as I possibly can now I'm
talking mechanical kitchen appliances
anything that can substitute any manual
labor that I may have to do and then the
second way I'm going to try it is using
nothing but good old-fashioned analog
tools no specialized pieces of equipment
just knives spoons pots and pans because
I want to know how much time do these
actually save is using only the most
basic equipment that much more work and
when it comes time to eat can you even
taste the difference let's make our
tomato sauce now I'm going to be making
a smooth tomato sauce some people like
chunky some people like smooth I'm going
with smooth for this I'm going to be
using a food mill I'm actually using
this because it's got two purposes and
one it crushes my tomatoes down to the
exact consistency that I want and it
filters out all of the seeds and sort of
fibrous bits that I don't want in my
sauce oh yeah there we go all right
got out all of that skin and seed bits
is why I love food mill and then of
course get all that nice little pulp on
the bottom here's where things get into
uncharted waters for me I want to make a
sauce that has the same smooth
consistency but I can't use a food mill
to break down my tomatoes my thought
process right now is to use a fine mesh
sieve and a wooden spoon to try and like
press it through I'm gonna try with one
tomato okay honestly that's kind of
working look at that you don't need a
food mill you just need a fine mesh
strainer a spoon and a little bit of
elbow grease look at that this is messy
this is exhausting I think I got about
all that I want at that because this is
just
seeds and skin at this point all right
so let's break this down the food mill
gets points for being significantly
quicker and less effort while the sieve
was tiring and messy
that being said the results look the
same so they both get one point each of
course your sauce is complete without
garlic so I have to chop all this garlic
but why chop garlic when you can just
use one of these to supplement the whole
process but boom boom bada boom yeah
that too what like 30 seconds maybe so I
don't have the luxury of a garlic press
so I'm gonna finely chop this garlic by
hand one of the things that I'm really
noticing right now in comparison to
using the garlic press my hands are
really sticky right there feels nice and
finely chopped the garlic press was much
faster than chopping which is important
however effort wise while my hands were
sticky
I don't think chopping was that
challenging or difficult so they both
deserve credit for ease of use they also
both get a point for their quality
results the last thing I need to do is
finely chop this onion but I don't
really want to have to chop the entire
thing so I don't know about you but that
looks really finely chopped to me our
own Yong you have the roots okay place
your bets on whether or not I'm gonna
start crying
alright onion is nice and chopped up
once again the machine proved much
faster
that being said cutting by hand was not
that hard if anything it's comparable
since the food processor is sort of
overkill so I'm awarding them both a
point for ease of use
the results were also pretty much the
same between the two it's time to make
meatballs so I have here beef chuck and
pork shoulder which I am going to grind
myself so first things first I'm just
gonna break this down into small pieces
and what's good about running your own
meat is you can control exactly the kind
of fat content that you want the kind of
meat that you want to use it gives you a
lot of flexibility and it gives you a
lot of room to make your own
improvements your own adjustments
oh the sound is just lovely and there
you have it
ground my own meat I have never had to
grind meat by hand I've had no
circumstances ever required it so
everything that I looked up said to
slice at like a 45 degree angle but
don't go all the way through flip it
back over honestly this isn't looking
too bad well I think my beef is done
that feels like it's in a good place
okay now time to do the pork great great
more it wasn't until this very moment
how much I realized that ground meat is
a luxury that was exhausting that was
that was more work than I anticipated it
being like my hand just cramped up
entire here and you know it's got to
keep on trucking it feels different not
in a bad way like I'm actually surprised
I was able to chop it as finely as I did
all we need to do now is just form these
guys into little meatballs meatballs are
done 24 minutes and 46 seconds so 34
minutes 44 seconds so about 10 minutes
slower than using a meat grinder
timewise is not bad
I think timewise that's totally okay
effort wise it is way more work and the
meat grinder was way better because I
wasn't as exhausted afterwards the meat
grinder is definitely the star here it's
faster and easier but the quality of the
meatballs seems pretty much the same so
they both get a point
most pasta you need with your hands but
why knead by hand when you can use a
food processor to knead for you which
fun fact about me was how I learned to
make pasta growing up we would always do
it in the food processor and then
finished off on the counter hello friend
alright we're gonna do spring test look
at that and that took nine minutes and
32 seconds pasta dough no technology no
food processor only by hand the
old-fashioned
grandmother way and I make myself a
little well they're going to add my egg
yolks my olio just a little pinch of
salt all right here we go
that feels congeals enough see the thing
about pasta dough's it shouldn't be like
super wet shouldn't be like bread dough
just gonna break a sweat here I can feel
it getting spring here oh oh man I'm out
of shape
this feels pretty good yes bring right
back it's been a little over 23 minutes
so vas double the time it took to make
it in a food processor kneading dough in
a food processor it's quick and takes
next to nil work kneading by hands takes
more time and a bit more sweating tears
but again their final product seemed
quite comparable so they both get a
point for that my dough is nice and
rested which means that all I need to do
for my machining is to just flatten and
cut my pasta noodles that you want to
gradually increase the thinness don't
want to go all in at once yeah and I can
just see my fingers through it mmm
there are two different cut settings on
this pasta maker I'm going to be going
with the wider one this is the
fettuccine and the only reason that I'm
doing that is I don't think I can cut
the noodles thin enough to the smallest
setting on here so I think a wider
flatter noodle will work a lot better
for my purposes moment of truth
[Music]
that's not half bad that right there is
the machine cut pasta that smells
amazing
looks amazing to me looks almost ready
to eat so that took a hand total of 42
minutes at 14 seconds hand-cut pasta I
expect it to take longer than it did
with the pasta maker here we go
[Music]
see my hands through it yeah see my
hands do that
so now moment of truth I'm going to
attempt a hand cut my own fettuccine
okay okay whoo that might be a little
bit thick
that's hand-cut fettuccine right there
all right let's do that eight more times
[Music]
math is the last of our hand-cut pasta
dough hmm 23 minutes and 32 seconds that
took half the time it did for me to go
through the pasta machine this was a bit
of a surprise
I think constantly adjusting the machine
settings made it tape longer so props to
the hand made for being quicker both
ways are pretty easy so I think they
both deserve points for ease of use and
the final pastas both looked great so I
think they both deserve points for that
all right it has been a long day there's
been a lot of cooking we have handmade
versus machine made pasta versus pasta
meatballs vs. meatballs sauce vs. sauce
I want to see if one tastes better than
the other and if you can tell the
difference between the two just got to
cook the pasta and throw this all
together all right what do we have here
okay so Betsy we have two pastas in
front of you okay the recipe for the
pasta the meatballs and the sauce is the
exact same for both but there's one
difference between the two this one
first
twirl twirl twirl that's really good
I feel like the first one has more
flavor versus the second one if I wasn't
like looking for a difference I probably
would be like oh this is great but like
to mean this one just had more flavor
versus this one this one everything was
done by hand this one was made using
nothing but appliances interesting so
you like the all handmade one yeah very
cool but it requires the floor work
awesome well thank you Betsy thanks Matt
and there you have it those slim Betsy
felt the handmade tasted better but
unfortunately that's not enough to raise
this total point value over machine-made
and it just goes to show that no matter
how much equipment you have or how
little equipment you have you can still
pull off a quality dish the sweet spot
is a mix of both appliances and both
handmade and I'm really happy with how
both of these turned out I'm definitely
gonna take both of these home and eat
both of them over the next three days
have a good one
[Music]
you
[Music]